uh joining me here uh as he helping us
take
us to him and michael smith
uh every single day when we're done here
on nbc sports on peacock at 3 p.m
eastern time we hand
off the nbc sports on peacock channel
two brother from another michael holly
joining us once again how are you
michael
rich i'm doing great and yes we'll do it
we'll keep the rotation going okay good
absolutely i'd love to
and answer your questions yes how many
brothers we got lots of them including
i was calling him our brother chris sims
yes
he had all kinds of jokes saying he was
a token white guy
i was like come on sims like what why
why we gotta like why we gotta go there
you know like
you we love you yes who cares we got
different daddies
it doesn't matter you all part of family
yes
so he had to make that about you know he
had to make it about race and everything
but i'm gonna tell you today yes he's my
step-brother today
he's my step-brother chris sims he's on
he's on your show
okay he used to be last week he was my
brother
uh you know thanksgiving at the same
table everything's good
what happened this week he's my step
brother because i don't know what
happened to him
uh maybe he bumped his head with his
foot you see these quarterback rankings
he came out with i did not enlighten me
what happened
i didn't know i know i know a good
michigan man well michigan wasn't smart
enough to play him when he was there but
that's okay
um i know a good michigan man tom brady
yes
was not in his top ten not in his top
ten quarterbacks
this year like what what's he thinking
well i guess uh let me just guess then
who he's got up there
so he must have right hill tat okay
tannehill over brady that now that's
fighting words
deshawn watson well desean i i could i
could kind of understand that
really yeah i mean tom is 44 years old
right i mean three 43 i know i'm
rounding up just trying to help him with
his uh with his uh equation
so that's what you're going to be
talking about with chris i mean this is
a big game tonight too man this is a
huge game tonight
i'm very excited for for kyler v
uh russ this evening for weekly we got
in this game
you know what that's a great question
i've been going back and forth here
so uh chris look it up when was the last
time a pete carroll team lost three in a
row
when was that last time i i don't know
when it was but
uh i'm not gonna sit here and say that
the the seahawks don't have
um deficiencies that arizona can
take advantage of and my concern is
arizona has had trouble closing games
including the win against seattle
including what we saw against buffalo
that they just when they need to pick up
a first down late they haven't when
kyler murray needs to pick one up he's
ending up throwing it
and uh instead of running it and vice
versa they've been out of sync but i'm
i'm
i'm leaning towards arizona tonight what
about you
yeah arizona i'm going with arizona too
but to bring up a great point
from from sunday that nobody's talking
about because of that great finish
uh calendar deandre hopkins there in the
end zone over three guys
he usually don't throw in a triple
coverage and come away happy about it
but
yeah it's deandre hopkins but on the
drive before that
cliff kingsbury kind of messed it up uh
all he had to do was kind of eat some
clock and they threw i think they
i think they threw three times to hand
it over to buffalo to allow josh allen
and buffalo to go ahead
so if they didn't have that big comeback
that big throw
i think i think kingsbury would have
been facing some tough questions but
i think the catch took took all that
away it is
one of those again where um
where arizona has been you know shooting
themselves in the foot a little bit with
decision making and then execution
towards the end of the game
but they are still six and three and i
don't know i mean
we've all seen momentum and what a
fickle beast it can be but how
how how you can take it from one game to
another and it's only been four days
i i i i think i'm gonna go with arizona
tonight i i think that's where
i think you've helped me talk this one
out i think that's the way i'm gonna get
rich don't you feel like
don't you feel like i know 2020 has been
weird in a lot of ways
away from sports but if i told you last
year that we're talking about arizona
in a position to sweep seattle uh
in a season series that the cleveland
browns
came off a big win and they're six and
three that buffalo
is leading the afc east and they could
have been eight and two
if not for that last uh last second
catch
i mean think about tampa bay is seven
and three
you feel like you're in some kind of
alternate reality don't you
yeah it is just it's one of those crazy
years
and it's one of those years in which
it's any given sunday
um and it's been happening um and it's
been weird
if i'm not mistaken chris has pete
carroll ever lost three games in a row
last time uh yeah no they did it in 2011
was the last time
they lost three in a row to cleveland
cincinnati and dallas they finished
seven and nine then
i've got this up right here the
quarterbacks in that game were tavares
jackson and
uh the quarterback that uh jeff schaefer
the curb your enthusiasm and seinfeld
writer and producer
and director um would call clipboard
jesus charlie whitehurst was his uh
quarterback rich that was a year at a
big run that's when they they
they hosted a playoff game everybody was
mad about it
because they were seven and nine they
played the saints and then marshawn
lynch
broke 70 tackles and then had an
interesting celebration in the end zone
actually it was the year after that
to be honest with you and it's one of
those or about the year after well 2010
was the year in which they
they beat the defending champion new
orleans saints in that game and that was
the beast quake a year after they lost
300 right after the it's
it's kind of you know that was 2010 year
before they lost three in a row
and i remember being uh in seattle all
those years ago before
russell wilson showed up and we were
asking pete carroll after the game
as we were being showered by skittles by
the way in the corner
on our nfl network set was asking who
you know
what's the identity of this team because
this was pre-legion of boom and
pre-russell wilson
and we're wondering like pete was the
identity and so was marshawn lynch and
then we all know
the kind of the the rest is history i've
got michael holly here we'll take him to
brother from another
what is your i don't want to steal too
much of whatever you're talking about
but i
you know the klay thompson news is
significant i wonder what you think of
it yeah
yeah it's tough because i was you know
michael smith asked me yesterday
when we didn't know the news and going
into the draft he said okay
what team are you most intrigued by and
i think he said the hawks
yeah because i already got some young
talent number six pick what would the
hawks do i said
golden state because if you have klay
thompson coming back
and you got curry coming back you still
got draymond you got the second pick
in the draft i was just intrigued and
see how andrew wiggins
plays with those guys i was just
intrigued by golden state because i
thought they'd be right back in the
championship conversation but
uh klay thompson missing another season
second season in a row it's just gonna
be tough i mean the west is
the west is loaded anyway i just don't
think they have enough
uh without klay thompson to be back in
that conversation so
yeah that's devastating that's a big one
uh for us and we're also
you know this is uh we talk about some
serious serious issues
on uh brother from another like uh
michael b
jordan's best movies ranking them you
know that's coming up
so and that's based on his selection of
sexiest man alive
that's what you're saying sexiest man
alive yes
that's of course if john legend actually
relinquishes that title he might
actually be holding out and trying to
sue to keep his title i don't know
we'll see what happens you know i gotta
go i gotta
you know i got to go with michael b
jordan on that one i don't know
all right very good and the answer is
creed michael
i'm gonna tell you like listen i'm not
the one to
to say what what women are looking for
uh clearly
tj knows i've struggled with that most
of my life
and i was able to con a woman into
marrying me
man don't don't yeah definitely don't
tell her
don't tell her so michael b jordan his
best movie is fruitvale station i mean
that's to be honest
oh that's my top five rich oh i like
that that's a good rich
eisen oh yeah is officially a brother
from another
michael let me tell you a quick story
let me just tell you a quick story
michael
okay and then uh we'll send you to your
your coverage
uh the do i have to i like hanging out
with you guys oh it's all good
no no no i think i am contractually
mandated to hand off the show at the top
of the hour
um this was the uh all-star game in new
york city
uh the one that was featured in the last
dance because it was kobe bryant's with
michael jordan
and um i did sportscenter with stuart
scott and we were coming down
on saturday night after um doing a
sports center he wasn't too thrilled
about doing that sportscenter saturday
night because he wanted to be in new
york city
for this big huge all-star game so
anyway we're we're we're driving down
uh and we go to uh times square uh where
the old all-star cafe if you remember
that with tiger
and uh and jack and ken griffey and what
gretzky had their restaurant or whatever
like a sports version of planet
hollywood
um it was around 1 30 in the morning and
everyone was
streaming out of uh the all-star cafe uh
because the party that mike uh that
stewart wanted to go to it just ended
stuart gets out of the car and he's like
i'm gonna ask this cop where the next
party is i'm like what are you doing
literally gone out of time square cars
running
got out of the car asked the police
officer where the next party is
got back in and said i got the
information let's get out of the car
because we were you know stuart had a we
had a service drive us down
got out of the car okay and started
walking
west towards the um uh lincoln tunnel
and i grew up in new york city i'd not
really spent much time in that part of
the neighborhood
i was literally the only white guy on
the street at that point in time
stuart scott it was like elvis had
entered the building
and everybody started flocking around
him telling
him how much they loved him and then one
guy looked at me and goes hey
the white guy
[Laughter]
okay michael i've been the white guy for
a long time
no matter what you're saying hey michael
rich is definitely invited to the
barbecue man
oh yeah he's there aka the black rich
eisen that's what shaq
himself said back in the day okay i'll
take that rick eisen
is at the barbecue sitting at the table
just chilling michael have a good show
yes how about dominoes you play dominoes
um i've had
dominos
when i went to school in michigan ann
arbor you're there
we love you you're there don't worry
about it we will take care of all the
other stuff
thank you michael you take care we'll
see you at the big hurdle
okay no have a great show with michael
smith i enjoy our chats on thursdays and
tell michael i said hi
there you go i just want to make sure
all right all right tj later brother
right away tj cowboys
cowboys two wins haha there you go
that's mike
ignorance that's kind of a jewish
goodbye with a brother from another he
says i'm an honorary man i am going to
leave mike he is too you don't want to
leave
i love that that was unnecessary at the
end though he didn't have to slip that
in there